how are you Devante I'm better for
watching you work sir and I thank you
for what you've done it for my fantasy
team through the first two weeks of this
season hey no problem and that's what
we're for
it's what you are here for and there was
so much conversation about how you were
about to take yet another major step up
in your career with Aaron Rodgers and
this new offense going into the season
and the first two weeks are certainly
barring that out I'm wondering how this
all works for you Devante I mean I've
got a lot of pieces around things are
kind of set up for me to succeed at this
point that the you know this court
record began throw me the ball do all
things come in big time potential you
know you've seen yourself in squid LA in
the learning and that guys have a lot of
success obviously you know a respected
area so when that came in I just kind of
thought it up sooner to take the next
step like you said you know everything's
kind of set up that way so I'll just
figure out just go ahead and do it
so the offense that Lafleur is brought
in I mean my gosh I've done this for 17
years now at the NFL Network and five
years now with this show I can't recall
another time where there was so much
scrutiny on what the offense is and the
scheme and the quarterback and how it's
different from the previous
administration and era where do you
stand on this subject
Devante I mean well you know all of this
is kind of generated behind the fact
that and it has been to me they're
airing tonight and mica spent so much
time together over the past 14 years or
whatever so I think that's that's what
kind of generates all of that but I'm
just kind of living in a moment right
now you know obviously I was able to
have some success under under Mike's
rain but that coming in and being like I
said there's a lot of power golf and
saying you know making a lot of things
look alike and it's going to put these
defenses in a bond so I'm just I'm just
here for production and leaving all that
you know the whole stuff in the past but
you know we've been able to have some
success and looking forward to keeping
that going well I mean
the whole preseason it was an training
camp what does it look like we didn't
know what it looks like now the first
two weeks were wondering if what it's
looking like is anything what it's going
to resemble a month from now how
advanced are you and the rest of the
team in this offense right now you know
I think as you can see to go even with
the hold off instead we come into the
season I think at this point in the
season it's not it it isn't now what
it's gonna be as we progress and get
through these games so you know that's
what any office let alone a new office I
think it's a work of progress right now
we we've shown that we can move the ball
we can do a lot of good things you know
we had a look below and I you know that
last game but it was nothing that's
discouraging anybody on this team
because you know we got all the pieces
and you know we obviously know it's a
it's been kind of a journey for us at
this point so we're kind of taking it
day-by-day to know right now so we love
that and I'm just going to continue to
build off all weekend and the
conversation your coach and quarterback
had captured by cameras that neither of
these guys say is much ado about
anything what can you tell me about it
yeah I mean that's really that's how I
look at it like I'm sure Matt said it's
not gonna be generally be the last time
that they had you know a situation like
that go on or you know maybe Matt 911 CR
I'll have our differences but you know
it's constructive and we invite that
type of thing everybody's got a lot of
passionate guys in that locker room the
same with the staff so times what we
don't always agree with you got a lot of
powerful powerful figures or you know
interested in mind but the chains of
football I think is good for the team
and which would be something it'll all
get better as we go Davante Adams
Packers wide receiver he's made the Pro
Bowl last two years he gets better every
year right here on the Rich Eisen show
and you mentioned Aaron being the best
quarterback in the league
you're from Palo Alto he's from Chico to
Northern California guys hooking up
every single week in the NFL all what
was your first real
actually when you met Aaron Rodgers
Devante my persons muffled kind of time
talking to him was when I first got
chapter as Marvin to court hero my wife
out of coach at the time if I grabbed
his number and he takes it in the ass go
to school so he sent in his number and I
text him just kind of well first I
called him and just let them avoid
obviously didn't recognize a number so
he didn't answer left voice outside of
attacks and say I'm going to get to work
obviously I'm excited I feel awkward
back this is that then he called me back
later on and I was the first time that
actually talked to him you know there's
a little party with the family unspotted
I just got jacked
so everybody's excited we all laughing
I'm telling you buddy shut up at the
house parents calling me everybody
freaking out because obviously he knows
it's a new start of my life is to have
the critic you know future yellowjacket
could be calling me on the phone was
pretty a pretty big deal so I was my
first time dealing with him and then got
the green lady we had a chance to kind
of catch up a little bit and he told me
that he took a loss before wasn't a lot
so well I mean so now I mean obviously
your relationship has advanced way past
that right now what what is it like when
you are in a huddle with him and it's
third and short game on the line walk me
through what that's like between the two
of you top wide receiver Pro Bowl wide
receiver and as you mentioned future
gold jacket I mean it's at this point
you know it's changes definitely
different films is all the comfort and
you know we communicate a lot more in
the huddle didn't know we had maybe my
first two maybe even three years in a
way you know the years we have the game
now so we there's a lot of chemistry we
kind of know one another spanking
especially host our situation attention
so we want a couple games together so a
lot of a lot of what's going on again
trying to figure out what different
individual cuts up they won't work what
concepts I'm interested in what he
thinks are you nobody's on what I've
been seeing throughout the games we
gotta just just move the offense from
there and I think it's been working
pretty well so far so I don't see that
changing Devon
two minutes left with the the packers
wide receiver here on the Rich Eisen
show your quarterback before Aaron
Rodgers many people might not know Derek
Carr from Fresno and you guys
reconnected prior to that game in in
Canada the 80 yard field game earlier
this yeah
earlier this this summer have you
connected with did you stay in contact
with Derek through everything that's
happened over the last few weeks or is
that just a one-shot deal when you saw
him there
no yeah we coming aired lives lesson in
quarter-mile away from in California now
see so we see each other quite a bit
obviously we keep up and talk at least
every week so we still throwing
everything in all season I've been able
to keep up with them throughout this
this past few weeks and ever since can't
but all the drama going off he's been
pretty cool about I mean you know
obviously it's been a lot and watch
something is really hit everybody over
there especially not him I think he's
just trying to keep focus at this point
got a cool one and one start right now
so I think he's just trying to lock in
on what they got going on over there and
he's been pretty positive about it
overall yeah the photograph we showed of
you and Derek also had Antonio Brown in
the middle of the two of you when you
were there what sense did you have that
something might be amiss or a rye with
Antonio and the Raiders when we worked
out that fix you mentioned is I mean I
was from the day I think I was like two
days after he signed we heard the word
we were in a Bay okay and you know there
to not been throwing and we throw I mean
twice a week in our season so it's
something we had been doing and maybe
wanted to join so he came and everything
was slow that I never saw anything that
potentially could could look like it
would not work out and you know they
seemed like they hit it off pretty well
so I don't know if anything just kind of
took a turn for the worse I guess as it
progressed but you know it is at this
point what do you think of when you hear
Davante Adams receivers referred to as
divas I think it's in situation of you
you have some of those guys out there
where you know still had that situation
but this is definitely not a minute
saying you hear that about in addition
how about any type of player at each
other stereotype was but it just depends
on who you are as a player and who you
are as a man we have all won sevens all
the blow okay there's one seven two one
two I'm open do you do that oh yeah I'll
definitely tell them that I don't scream
it for the cameras but definitely talk
about that at home get to the side well
I mean does he basically see I mean he
kind of knows though doesn't even you're
open I mean he's wrong you know I mean
that same situation had come home what
her near walk off and in Dallas in 2017
he told me I said and I came back to the
play before and told Authority game he
just looked at me and he told everybody
that that's got a look in my eyes I said
throw a better ball which is not what I
said
communicate yeah Erin works on a higher
plane Devante you know that I mean like
he he might read the things he sees a
deep thinker that that that twelve you
know and but no no Canadian tuxedo for
you and the blue jeans that wasn't in
the cards for you know I didn't you know
I didn't I just took it out of my
clothes I had to wait for me there oh
but so you had it already in the chute
is that what you're saying you had it
all right hey Devante keep doing what
you're doing not only because you're
you're one to root for but again man
spread centerpiece is the name of our
team because I don't know if you saw the
coaching photograph at this year's
owners meeting Andy
was right in the middle put his legs
wherever the hell he damn pleased and
it's just they just did the man spread
centerpiece that's the name of our team
that's our logo and oh and you are our
lead receiver every week Devante I love
it I appreciate all the support of
course keep going and we'll call we'll
call later on in the season and just
revisit I appreciate the call here you
got it that's Davante Adams at Tay tae
15 Adams on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app